[Musique]
aux fourneaux faut qu'on sache
aujourd'hui on va dans le comparatif
dont je vous ai déjà parlé entre d'un
côté le poke ophone xiaomi la f1 et de
l'autre côté le honneur plaît avant tout
de chose j'ai reçus de colis ou curieux
de savoir ce que c'est ce moment c'est
la folie des colis qu'est ce que c'est
waouh ça ça va être un super test c'est
la tique watch procès une montre
connectés je l'avais vu il ya quelques
jours lorsque j'étais à l'ifa
mon serveur et l'on voit pour l'attester
c'est vraiment un truc de ouf
une vraie super montre avec un écran
raid enfin ce qui est vraiment génial
donc ça je vous invite à faire une chose
c'est à vous abonner à rester qualité
parce qu'on va vraiment parler c'est
vraiment je pas si vous aviez bien c'est
vraiment une montre un qui est
génialissime connecter à google
assistant il ya pas mal de choses à
faire avec ces du webos pays google bien
évidemment pas voir cédric est super
cool et ici ça pour au final avoir ça
c'est un travail noble de targus
c'est un petit outil pour voyager qui
pètent pas mal d'indiens ce que je vais
faire c'est que je vais l'emmener avec
moi demain on part avec chien miami l'an
on va les voir un petit peu tout
l'écosystème qui a autour de deux chiens
ont mis en europe et ça justement c'est
un petit dock qui est pas mal qui nous
permettra de voir quand on voyage un peu
comment on peut utiliser un outil qui
verra ça demain ça vient avec moi ok
cool
donc on va tout de suite faire ce
comparatif entre les deux smartphones
gamer milieu de gamme de cette rentrée
de septembre 2018 parce que d'un côté
vous avez lepoko phone de chez omis le
nouveau modèle f1 le fn c'est vraiment
pour montrer la puissance avec un stand
ragots 845 si giga de ram de la côte est
vous avez le honor play un partenariat
avec audi également de la puissance d'un
kirin 970 4 gigas de ram ya pas mal de
deux points de différence on s'est
produit donc ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va les comparer point par point
point par point marche mieux comme ça
point par point on va regarder le design
la performance photo vidéo le gaming
bien évidemment la batterie
il la rapidité tout ça tout ça j'en
passe et des meilleurs donc on va se
faire un truc hyper scolaire on a un
grand tableau avec poco fa llait fin au
nord plaît et on va regarder les
différentes catégories
le design l'écran la puissance
performance photo vidéo audio le total
ça nous fait en tout 1 2 3 4 5 ça nous
fait en tout cinq critères différents
pour essayer de juger ces produits pour
savoir lequel est meilleur l'idée c'est
vraiment de voir quelque chose de
complètement objectif on prend les
résultats on prend le chiffre le plus
haut on prend la meilleure performance
entrant meilleurs trucs et ensuite on
désignera le champion toute catégorie
entre deux poids-lourds d'un côté le
poke ophone f1 le honor player j'ai une
petite question laquelle je veux
répondre sur twitter qui a été posé et
merci d'ailleurs à honor d'avoir pris la
peine d'y répondre mais puisque c'est ce
que tout le monde l'a pas vu je vais
vous répondre ça samedi lumière est très
très forte entre le au nord 10 et le
honor play lequel est meilleur en termes
de photos/vidéos le aux nordistes est
meilleur que les honneurs play en termes
de photos vidéos si maintenant vous
voulez un produit qui est excellent en
termes de photos vidéos qui est
excellent en terme de limites il faut
aller sans le view 10 comme ça au moins
vous aurez un produit qui est top
néanmoins celui-ci est bon on va tous
vous inquiétez pas si vous le prenez
vous serez pas déçus
comme d'habitude j'ai bien travaillé
bloc notes je suis tout près dessus donc
on va regarder on va commencer tout de
suite par un côté design
je pense que s'il ya bien un point de
comparaison qui vraiment subjectif là
dedans c'est le côté design parce que
vous avez deux produits qui sont quand
même relativement différent du côté du
prokofiev 1 vous avez un dos en
polycarbonate alors le polycarbonate si
vous savez pas c'est du plastique
néanmoins faut quand même qu'il a trait
au lycée fait le fait d'avoir un capteur
photo au centre c'est vraiment bien et
en plus de ça je suis amoureux des
petits ronds rouges autour des objectifs
coup c'est hyper élégant il est très
très bien alignées avec le capteur
d'empreinte digitale au centre le fait
de retrouver la marque poko phone au
milieu ça donne un côté vraiment très
élégant c'est simple c'est assez
linéaire simple sobre épuré
c'est pour moi en tout cas ce côté là
très très joli
de l'autre côté vous avez le honor
playes avec un dos métal unibody un côté
tout de suite un peu plus classieux que
sur ce produit là néanmoins c'est très
très personnelle à ce que j'en très bien
que c'est hyper hyper subjectif je vais
pas en tenir compte dans le test mais
néanmoins j'aime un petit peu moins
l'appareil photo positionné sur le côté
j'aime bien par contre l'écriture ici à
une caméra
j'aime bien le branding au nord là
j'aime assez - le côté marqué c'est eux
ici j'ai pas si vous voyez bien mais bon
ailier de toute façon il y est également
ici mais il se voit quand même vachement
moins sur le poteau phone après ce qui
est très sympa aussi sur ce modèle là là
c'est cette petite lise règles vous
retrouvez en haut est ici qui vient
passer jusque sur les côtés à l'avant ce
sont deux smartphones qui se ressemblent
énormément vous avez tous les deux une
encoche l'encoche du propofol sera un
tout petit peu plus large que l'on
gauche duo north plaît vous avez des
coins arrondis peut-être un petit peu
plus de bord noir ici sur le poteau
phone que de l'autre côté la barre en
bas peut-être un petit peu plus large
sur le poteau phone les designs sont
quand même relativement similaire ajoute
un petit peu plus minimaliste je vais
peut-être préféré le devant du honor
playes je vais préférer par contre le
dos du proco phone donc si on pouvait se
faire un poco playes je pense que
j'aurai en point de vue design le
produit parfait en terme de points
focaux phone fait 186 g 1,5 tandis que
le honor play fait 176 g
franchement pas du tout la différence
entre un truc qui pèse hyper lourd pour
moi il va vraiment de ce point de vue là
je préfère donc le dos du poteau phone
la face avant du nord play pour moi
c'est un point partout je peux
absolument pas à les départager sur ce
côté là que de toute façon c'est très
très personnel c'est hyper subjectif je
vous donne mon avis mais c'est compliqué
de poser une note d'un côté et de
l'autre pour un truc hyper subjectif on
va regarder maintenant du point de vue
de l'écran vous êtes toujours pourquoi
fine de ce côté-là eléonore paille de ce
côté là on va essayer vraiment de garder
cet ordre pour s'y repérer vous avez ici
à l'écran 6,18 poussée du lcd la potée
un écran 6 3 pouces est également du lcd
une résolution de 2246 par 1080 pixels
2340 par 1080 pixels
la densité de pixels cdu 416 p pays 410
pays autant vous dire que de ce point de
vue au sein de change globalement pas
grand chose est-ce qu'il y en a un qui
tire un peu plus sur le bleu que l'autre
ce serait une question vraiment point
détails
peut-être que les honneurs play tire un
peu plus vers le bleu que le propofol
mais on est vraiment sur une fois de
plus du point de détail pour moi
globalement
très peu de différence le rendu est
vraiment cool d'un côté comme de l'autre
vous pouvez venir vous mettre chaque
côté l'encoche va pas du tout venir
renier dans votre smartphone
il faut savoir que sur le honor plaît et
vous avez une puce graphique sunna et
rennes malijai 12ème pesos mp 12 pardon
et de l'autre côté sur le f1 de poko
phone vous avez une qualcomm adreno 630
alors peut-être une petite différence
est un peu plus de jaune ici un peu plus
de bleu je pense que l'écran du haut nos
plaies qui a un poil plus sur le bleu je
passe il sera évident pour vous avec la
colorimétrie l'image il ya une très
légère différence au niveau du visage
regarder lâcher un peu plus jaune
hélas un peu moi je vais quand même
mettre un point de plus vers le haut
nord play avec le quota peut plus bleuté
mais je préfère un peu mais globalement
c'est vraiment du point de détail ici
également ils sont franchement très très
difficiles à départager donc j'ai pas
trop me mouiller parce que je trouve que
les écrans sont quasi pareil
il tire un peu plus vers le bleu sur le
north plaignez vous pouvez complètement
le corriger directement dans les
paramètres
donc on peut pas compter ça comme un
défaut il y a pas que les étages
vraiment plus que l'autre je met
également un point de chaque côté bon et
maintenant on va parler en termes de
performance parce que je pense que c'est
là dessus qu'il ya vraiment une
différence qui va se faire parce que sur
le pokémon f1 vous avez un qualcomm
snapdragon 845 qui à ce jour le socle
plus puissant qui équipent des
smartphones alors je sais il ya le kirin
980 qui était présente et il est pas
très longtemps par wii qui est sur le
papier en tout cas beaucoup plus rapide
sauf que ceux qui rient 1980 pour
l'instant il est sûre aucun smartphone
dispose on peut donc dire que le temps
dragonne 845 reste pour l'instant le
socle plus puissants et de l'autre côté
vous avez un kirin 970 qui est très très
bien qu'ils donnent la gamme est le plus
puissant vous avez donc un match entre
le qualcomm snapdragon du 145 le peering
170 je sais pas si vous le savez mais le
plus rapide c'est le snapdragon 845 est
quand même un peu plus puissant que le
kirin 970 d'ailleurs c'est celui qui les
bat toussaint c'est lui qui va battre
aussi l exil aux sauts 9810 et il faut
savoir d'ailleurs que chez samsung
aux états unis on retrouve pas à
l'exigence 9810
sur les notes 9 et 9 on retrouve un coin
comme 845 donc en termes de perfs juste
sur le papier le pokémon est donné
vainqueur en termes de puissance et de
performances alors il ya aussi une autre
différence qui se fait dix points de vue
de la ram vous avez ici
si giga de ram vous avez sur celui ci 4
gigas de ram il y à deux gigas de ram
supplémentaire pour une utilisation
quotidienne c'est à dire faire l'email
partage sur les réseaux sociaux naviguer
allume et éteint tout ça franchement
vous ne l'êtes pas de différence les
deux héros très bien par contre 1 2 0
tandis que seul un petit peu plus
puissante un peu plus gourmande en
termes de performance je pense notamment
lors de gaming c'est vraiment la donne
de ces produits de guémy il se peut que
vous sentiez la différence ne sera pas
énorme ça sera plus du point de détail
mais il se peut qu'ils aient une
différence donc ça raconte quoi sans
papiers le koko von f1 est donné comme
étant plus rapide à savoir également que
ça ne s'arrête pas là sur le sur le
poteau fan f1 vous avez un
refroidissement liquide à l'intérieur
qu'à vous aider à répartir la chaleur
dès lors que le soldat se met à chauffer
franchement vos smartphones lors de
partygaming un petit peu un peu plus
hardcore risque de chauffer grâce au
refroidissement liquide va y avoir une
diffusion des chaleurs un smartphone qui
va chauffer beaucoup moins qui va du
coup beaucoup moins souffrir d'une
augmentation de température
tandis que sur le honor plaît vous
n'avez pas de refroidissement liquide
donc un smartphone qui potentiellement
peut chauffer un peu plus tard de
performance ont fait un test en toutes
les applications sont fermés comme ça au
moins on part sur une base saine
on va regarder maintenant l'ouverture
d'applications typiquement avec en tout
chaque côté se permettra justement de
faire le test
peut-être que j'appuyais avec un léger
décalage peut-être d'abord sur le poteau
phone et ensuite sur le honor play on va
laisser travailler pour voir la fin s'il
ya vraiment une très grosse différence
entre les deux
là il ya une différence je trouve par
contre que le snapdragon ici 845 va
beaucoup plus vite que le kirin 970
cellaouate ou d'incapacité calcul du
snapdragon 845 qui va franchement
franchement vite et il ya aussi une
différence si ce fait avec ses 2 gigas
de ram qui malgré tout apporte quand
même quelque chose sur des phases de
test sur un an tout c'est pas
négligeable
c'est marrant parce que tout au début
j'avais pas globalement différence entre
le stand dragonne 845,5 poco fa naissant
et sur le au north bay de côté avec le
kerry dans soixante dix mais plus le
test avance plus il ya une différence
qui se fait ressentir
on va vraiment qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus de puissance et
performance foutait du prokofiev uns par
rapport aux autres plaies qui met
beaucoup plus de temps le résultat tombe
tout de suivi sur le coffre-fort on à
262 1908 le honor plaie est toujours en
train de calculer on n'a pas encore le
résultat il devrait pas tarder d'ici
quelques instants attention voit le
résultat
204 1502 il va effectivement franchement
il va moins vite
j'ai l'impression d'être une course de
formule 1 je crois comme ça mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya une vraie vraie différence
entre les deux et on le voit vraiment au
niveau des résultats c'est très
significatif je me suis connecté sur le
site dans tous tous pour avoir eu leurs
résultats en tête
il nous met le black shark de schumi qui
est forcément dédié au gaming est
toujours le premier vivonne ex hop au
phénix et si on descend one + 6 note 9
on descend on descend on va trouver à la
8e place
le poc ophone f1 avec un résultat en
tout ou de 260 4311 bon moi je suis à
peu près avec un tout petit écart mais
c'est sensiblement sa et pour trouver le
honor plaît il faut descendre beaucoup
plus bas à la 30e place
donc là en terme de performances le
résultat est franchement sans appel pour
le coup je trouve que koko von ah
vraiment bien nommé son modèle le fx
casqués mans en 8e place des smartphones
les plus puissants du marché
actuellement mais là très clairement le
point revient de très loin
hop au cafouillage un jeton néanmoins
rassuré tout le monde les smartphones
vous allez les utiliser au quotidien
vous allez les bouger les solliciter
vous verrez pas de différence là la
différence avait vraiment la trouvait
lorsque vous allez chercher dans les
performances lorsque vous avez un petit
peu les secouer mais pour une ouverture
d'applications quelconque ça va s'ouvrir
exactement de la même manière
donc sur des cessions gaming vous verrez
globalement pas la différence je vous ai
fait des tests
avant-hier vous effet le théâtre hip hop
en f1 hier je vous ai fait le test du
honor plaît je vous invite à aller faire
un petit tour et à les regarder comme ça
vous verrez vraiment le détail sur pib
de chaque côté et que je teste à chaque
fois que je prends en gros en référence
vous verrez en termes de performances ce
qu'il dit est ce qu'il est intéressant
lequel peut aller plus vite
alors une fois de plus si vous avez
commandé un honneur plaît n'allez pas
leur vendre n'avez pas à vous en
débarrasser c'est un excellent
smartphone on est sur les smartphone
milieu de gamme pour des gamers donc
c'est pas parce que le snapdragon 845
allumé quand même une petite claque que
ça veut dire que vous allez avoir un pdg
qui rament typiquement lorsque j'ai fait
le test que j'ai mis pib gpg là tout est
proposé la qualité la plus élevée
ça veut dire qu'il a reconnu que
derrière il y avait quand même de la
puissance donc pour jouer à vos jeux
vous aurez pas de souci c'est vrai que
le pokémon tu as beaucoup plus vite
je pense qu'à terme on sentira quand
même une légère différence mais sur un
usage quotidien je pense qu'ils sont
très bien tous les deux néanmoins le
résultat est sans appel pour la
puissance on va donc mettre le point ici
au poteau phone f1 et 1 0 au nord plaît
on parle donc de performance sur ces
deux machines
il faut savoir que sur les honneurs
plaît vous avez le gpu turbo alors le
gpu turbo apporte beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'amélioration par rapport à un
modèle qui n'auraient pas le jpeg turbo
il est quand même 60 % plus rapide avec
le gpu turbo que sans les gpu turbo et
il vous permet d'économiser 30% de
batterie en plus donc ça apporte
vraiment en termes d'autonomie et en
termes de puissance et une amélioration
logicielle qui vous avez une différence
de batteries entre les deux soit pop en
f1 vous avez une batterie de 4 mille
milliards erreur sur le haut norplex
avec batterie de 3750 millan terreur les
deux smartphones ont de la recharge
rapide donc là dessus vous êtes
tranquille vous le branchez en une
demi-heure vous avez pas fait une charge
complète mais franchement ne veulent pas
très loin il se décharge pas très vite
c'est aussi l'intérêt d'avoir le gpu
turbo sur le honor play qui va vraiment
vous aider à économiser de la batterie
et c'est d'ailleurs tout l'enjeu tout ce
qui va arriver l'année prochaine avec
les nouveaux processeurs de qualcomm
avec le tir et 1980 ça va être vraiment
des machines qui vont être complètement
boosté à l'intelligence artificielle qui
va vraiment tenir optimisé
performance pour vous proposer de la
puissance quand vous en avez besoin pour
vraiment tout économiser lorsque vous
êtes vraiment sûr la session il père
tranquille et pour optimiser votre
batterie ça on en repart à l'année
prochaine parce que c'est vraiment ce
qui va arriver en 2019 avec les deux
smartphones vous tenu une autonomie
largement supérieur un jour un jour un
jour et demi au niveau de l'ouest avec
force alors ça je le compas dans le test
parce que c'est pareil c'est un goût
très très très personnel c'est compliqué
à quantifier
je préfère moi le mit lui pour poko
parce que vous avez je trouve un stade
la délégation qui est beaucoup plus
sympa ce système par onglets là est
beaucoup plus pratique on comprend très
bien le système de navigation aussi par
couleur est extrêmement intuitif
je trouve ça vraiment bien fait
extrêmement bien pensée de l'autre côté
un peu moins fan de em ui de huawei
je peux pas dire qu'il n'est pas bien ça
serait mentir il est vraiment bien vous
n'êtes pas tiroirs d'application si vous
le voulez il faut aller le chercher
directement dedans je le trouve un peu
moins cool il ya un peu moins de
possibilités un peu moins d'options mais
ça une fois de plus c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très personnel peut pas
du tout quantifier la qualité d'un
produit par rapport à ça c'est juste
c'est une affaire de goût à savoir que
les deux surcouche tourne sur android
aurait aux huit points mais aussi une
différence au niveau de l'audio les deux
sont pas du tout faits de la même
manière sur le pourquoi des fins vous
avez des hauts parleurs stéréo
vous avez un haut parleur ici et un
haut-parleur ici à utiliser le haut
parleur de la face avant et vous aurez
un peu plus de puissance par rapport au
nord play qui lui par contre n'a qu'un
haut parleur mono ici donc ça c'est le
poteau phone maintenant je vais vous
mettre le au north bay
la musique est cool mais il ya très
clairement une vraie différence c'est
compliqué de vous quantifier exactement
ça il veille à quel est le pourcentage
de différence mais il ya beaucoup plus
de puissance audio
du côté du pot-au-feu 9,1 par rapport au
nord play sur le online vous avez une
option qui est super bien pour
l'écoutent avec un casque vous avez
l'effet sonore owen wilson
ça c'est plutôt cool et c'est très
intéressant ça marche uniquement avec un
casque c'est un truc qui est fait que
pour le casque
donc c'est pas la peine vous pourrez pas
activée si vous n'êtes pas de cast lead
et si vous voulez ce qui est génial avec
ça c'est de vous dire comment est ce que
vous voulez que votre audio soit fait
avec votre casque c'est sur quelque
chose en 3d c'est quelque chose de
naturel pour vraiment avoir un son très
très naturel un son standard mais ce qui
est vraiment très intéressant est ce
qu'il faut enfin on évite faire lorsque
vous jouez si vous mettez le 2 3d ça
vous rajoute des petites options en
dessous pour savoir comment vous voulez
que votre son spatialisé et c'est top
vous avez ça quelque chose de rapprocher
très près de vous une station de fass
élargi grand grand match ça génial alors
après tout intérêt de ça à mon avis
c'est d'effectivement lorsque vous à
l'écouté de la musique pour avoir une
sensation de spatialisation ça c'est
vraiment top
après surtout lorsque vous allez jouer à
des jeux comme pdg lorsque vous avez des
ennemis qui arrivent un peu tous les
côtés à droite à gauche ce qui est
vraiment bien c'est que du coup vous
allez savoir exactement où il situe
termes de qualité audio et en termes de
puissance audio avec le casque ça c'est
le honor plaît le son est cool et là on
est surtout qu'aux fans ça à la va comme
vous l'entendez pas forcément
directement mais il y a vachement plus
de puissance audio sur le poteau phone
f1 que sur le honor plaît il faut
forcément accordé le point à celui qui a
le plus de jus et qui a la meilleure
qualité sur la partie audio le point
vient donc au poteau phone f1
on passe donc maintenant au test de la
partie photo vidéo et ça croyez moi
c'est pas rien non plus sur le propofol
ne vous avez des capteur de 12
mégapixels + 5 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 1.8 tandis que sur le
honor plaît et vous avez un double
capteur 16 mégapixels + 2 mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f 2.2 on a donc
plus
pixel du côté du honor plaît mais on a
une ouverture qui est beaucoup moins que
sur le poteau fois défend bon ça on va
les tester pour voir vraiment la
différence sur francophone f1 vous avez
une caméra la vente d'un méga pixels là
vous avez une caméra de 16 mégapixels
les deux smartphones sont boostés à
l'intelligence artificielle
reconnaissance de scène
optimisation des couleurs en fonction de
ce que vous aller photographier on va
maintenant regarder directement ce que
valent ces smartphones du côté de la
vidéo on a donc deux smartphones
d'un côté le pot-au-feu des fins de
l'autre côté le honor plaît alors je
suis complètement le passage sur le
capteur arrière dont je me rends pas du
tout content de ce que vous voyez ce que
ça donne dites nous ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire est ce que vous
préférez lepoko phone est ce que vous
préférez le haut norvège est coupée à
pau les lumières là j'ai coupé les
lumières pour un petit peu en conditions
de faible luminosité c'est un point
d'éclairage de côté c'est ma grosse
ampoule jaune
j'ai volé fermé de ce côté là dites moi
ce que vous en pensez
lequel vous séduit le plus et de quelle
selon vous à la meilleure qualité vous
avez une vraie vraie vraie différence au
niveau du visage
las un petit peu sur exposé au centre là
on a beaucoup plus de détails
l'image est vraiment de meilleure
qualité on est à quelque chose qui est
beaucoup plus contrastée beaucoup plus
de détails au niveau de la barbe
je bascule sur les caméras revanche
d'une caméra de 5 mégapixels sur le
proco phone ici sur le honor plaît j'ai
une caméra de 16 mégapixels alors là je
peux voir directement sur le moniteur je
me méfie parce que la qualité d'un écran
à l'autre peut toujours être un petit
peu différente mais c'est pareil là je
regarde j'ai une meilleure un meilleur
rendu détails sur le poteau phone ici et
là le rendu des couleurs le traitement
des couleurs le traitement de l'image
est complètement différent du côté de
chez au nord c'est vraiment très
impressionnant mais c'est vraiment très
impressionnant parce que là où on voit
vraiment la différence de traitement
d'image de choix qui est fait par la
marque
je préfère très clairement le
l'image du prokofiev 1 par rapport à
celle du bonheur plein maintenant je
vais simple lumière et on va regarder la
différence
jean coutu ne s'est pas là il ya ou
pourquoi connaissant le plus de lumière
je coupe la deuxième lumière donc là il
ya toujours mon ampoule de côté et là
c'est pareil alors j'ai plus de lumière
cette fois ci sur la caméra avant duo
nord plaît parce que j'ai une ouverture
de f 2.0
ça marche mieux que le f 2.2 c'est
vraiment très impressionnant quand même
mais néanmoins la voyez j'ai beaucoup
plus de bruit sur le honneur plaît que
sur le poke open f1 alors bon c'est pas
non plus l'idéal intentions on n'est pas
sur un truc de ouf
de toute façon on est sur des appareils
photos de smartphones donc on n'est pas
fait pour avoir un truc complètement
hallucinant mais il s'en sort beaucoup
mieux du côté de la vidéo le résultat
est franchement sans appel il ya rien à
dire le point va très clairement aux
profanes f1 qui va être beaucoup plus
lumineux qui aura un point de détail qui
sera beaucoup mieux que le honor playes
alors je vous le disais en début de
vidéo le honor planes n'est pas fait
pour faire d'excellentes photos six
voiliers de très belles photos vous
encourage vivement à aller sur le
nordiste qui juste d'ailleurs j'ai déjà
fait une vidéo dans laquelle j'avais
testé la caméra du nord 10 en vidéo et
en photos vous invite vraiment aller la
voir parce que on se rend vraiment
compte de toute la qualité de ce
smartphone
mais très clairement entre les deux en
terme de vidéo
c'est pourquoi fo n'est fait qu'importe
le point maintenant on va les tester la
photo pour voir lequel s'en sort le
mieux en terme de rendu photo c'est
vraiment marrant la côte édition des
locaux phone ici le honor plaît là sur
le moniteur le honor play s'en sort
beaucoup mieux
vous avez quelque chose qui est très
bien détaillés qui est franchement bien
fait j'aime bien ce que c'est alors
attention parce que selon leur plaît
c'est toujours extrêmement saturé voyez
la couleur est beaucoup plus à thuré là
sur le poteau folle il ya un côté un peu
plus jeunes sur le fond partout sur
l'image
c'est un peu plus chaud alors à quoi
sont des traitements d'image qui sont
liées aussi à l'intelligence
artificielle les choix sont différents
en fonction d'un smartphone à l'autre si
vous continuez à regarder
voilà on est sur la même problématique
là typiquement on est seule chose qui
est sûre saturé je sais pas si vous le
voyez c'est très très très vive comme
couleur alors on fait attention parce
que là je fais sur l'écran mais
d'exporter vous allez voir je vais les
mettre juste après ça risque vraiment
d'être différent là par contre à côte un
peu plus naturel mais effectivement un
côté un peu plus jaune c'est un choix
traitement d'image qui est fait
là-dessus également là
aalors l'aop jolies têtes de vainqueurs
là j'ai un mode portrait là j'ai pas de
mode portrait je préfère la caméra de
celle filles du poc ophone à celle du
honor plaît je sais pas mal aussi
c'est vraiment fait pour faire sortir
des détails mais par contre voyez là ça
me lis un peu plus là ça fait peut se
sortir les rides des choses comme ça
donc bon je préfère celle là ensuite on
continue avec hop voilà c'est celle-là
on continue avec une paire de chaussures
non vous avez mais new balance
là on est si beaucoup plus saturé il
sait quelque chose de beaucoup plus
naturelle n'y arriverais différence je
vous dis no 6 en termes de traitement
d'image les deux se valent
pour moi les deux en termes de photos
sont pas mal autant quand la photo c'est
plus difficile de les départager autant
sur la vidéo très clairement mais très
clairement le point
vao poko phone f1 qui vous fera surtout
des vidéos de meilleure qualité surtout
en faible luminosité en photo vidéo le
point va donc également aux poneys fin
et pas de point pour le haut noir
plaident les deux smartphones se
recharge en usb type c'est ce qui est
très bien les deux smartphones ont un
port jack sur le aux normes play le port
dock se trouve en bas ici sur le poteau
phone il se situe sur le haut
les deux smartphones ont bien évidemment
début tous mes palmes et bluetooth sur
le poker en f1 vous avez un bluetooth
5.0 tandis que sur l'autre plaie vous
avez un bout tous 4.2 je crois qu'il est
l'heure de faire les comptes pour que
fan f1 on a un point en design on a un
point pour l'écran on a un point en
puissance on a un point en photo vidéo
on a un point en audio ça nous fait donc
1 2 3 4 5
ça nous fait donc un total de cinq sur
cinq
on compare maintenant au nord play le
aux normes mais on a un point en design
on a un point pour l'écran on a zéro
pour la puissance le pointer donner aux
poteaux phone 0 pour la vidéo photo le
pointer de l'époque au fon 0 pour
l'audio le point était de nos colonnes
samedi donc un résultat de 2
sur cinq alors attention quand même
parce que je suis pas en train de dire
que le honor planes n'a pas les moyens
et c'est pas un smartphone qui mérite
d'avoir mis en jeu juste de dire que par
rapport à la numérotation je décide de
donner le point à l'autre pour le design
très très compliqué à départager parce
que les designs ses affaires du goût
donc je peux pas le départage et donc
donne un point partout fortunade zéro
partout mais bon c'est à dire 0 les
designs son panache bien au contraire
les écrans se valent un point partout la
puissance très clairement le snapdragon
845 couple est assis giga de ram plus de
refroidissement liquide
il va vraiment au dessus la photo vidéo
le honor planes est pas un photophone
qui est vraiment bien pour faire des
souvenirs les partager sur les réseaux
sociaux pour vous prendre en photo avec
des ennemis ça ira parfaitement bien
mais c'est vrai que en les comparant
point par point le poko phone est quand
même supérieur en termes de qualité et
du point de vue de l'audio le fait
d'avoir un haut parleur mono sur le
honor plaît d'avoir des hauts parleurs
stéréo softphone ça fait la différence
et il ya aussi une vraie différence du
coût de niveau mais aussi une différence
de niveau
en l'écoutant au casque il ya un regain
de puissance soit poko phone est fin et
ça c'est quand même pas négligeable
alors attention je le répète n'écoutez
pas de la musique qu'écoutaient pas des
jeux trop fort l'idée c'est pas de se
rendre sourd je le pousse à fond c'est
juste pour un test est pas non plus pour
me dire il faut écouter de la musique à
fond tout le temps c'est pas du tout le
cas attention présenter vos oreilles
voilà donc pour ce résultat entre ces
deux smartphones milieu de gamme pour
gamer pour cette rentrée 2010 8
très clairement le propofol est au
dessus du honor plaît néanmoins si vous
avez acheté l'honneur plaît vous serez
pas déçus on n'allait pas le revendre
pour acheter le propofol
il est très bien mais dans le cadre du
test c'est sans appel
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
termes de design qu'est ce que vous
préférez est ce que vous préférez le
design du proco phone est ce que vous
préférez le design du honor play lequel
vous fait de l'oeil lequel pourrait vous
tentez fils y en a qui vous botte je
vous ai mis des liens en bas dans la
description pour le trouver au meilleur
tarif
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
demain on part très très tôt un mélange
d'un avion à 6h du mat
ça va être très compliqué encore demain
mais bon c'est pas d'ailleurs demain on
part à milan on va voir xiaomi pour voir
un petit peu tout l'écosystème shiomi
d'ailleurs être cool peut-être des
nouveautés on va les voir m'a posé la
question pour le mil 8 explorer édition
de savoir s'il va arriver en france oui
quand quoi comment voilà donc demain on
reparle de shiori vous invite donc à
faire une seule chose c'est à vous
abonner et à rester connectés chaud
[Musique]
oh